[Music]
box is a cloud-based platform and an
application both for end-users to more
effectively share business information
work with their colleagues in a more
effective way than they've been able to
do before the Box is currently serving
over 200,000 unique businesses around
the world very very small mom-and-pop
shops companies of even 3 to 5 people
all the way up to some of the world's
largest organizations that are
multinational in nature more than half
of our Android users come from outside
the United States Android like box I
think has this wonderful openness and
kind of natural traction but you get a
lot of adoption virally you get a lot of
people who really love their Android
device so I love the fact that we share
a common philosophy in openness for our
customers we've seen over 5 million
downloads of the Android application on
both phones and tablets I'm really
excited that Fox has such a big focus on
mobile right now we have a full suite of
mobile apps boxer Android is starting to
pick up a lot of traction in the
enterprise as well the Android system
makes localization easy and simple and
also Android is really flexible so
there's a lot of things we can do on
Android that we can't do on other
platforms the developer console helps us
understand our user base more and lets
us see where they are from lets us see
what devices they're using what version
of Android they're running and lets us
see the reviews and ratings lets us
respond to those reviews what I love
about the Android platform is that we
control how fast we iterate on the
product and what we ship to consumers
and win we also love the fact that we
can do rolling rollouts of the product
through testing we typically roll out a
new release to about 10% of our user
base and we monitor how the application
is behaving we monitor both performance
and usage of the application and
typically after a half a day we roll it
out to 50% of our user base and perhaps
after 24 hours we roll out to 100% it's
been a great help in making sure our
application is flawless one of the
examples of leading a feature on Android
is the ability to add collaborators to
folders the first mobile implementation
of
that was on Android the Android is a
great platform for iterating and getting
consumer feedback and Enterprise
feedback very quickly
[Music]